hi this is presh talwalkar
how predictable are you
let's find out in this video
in front of you are the numbers 1
through 16.
to get started i want you to pick a
number you can pick any of these 16
numbers
but you should remember which number
you've picked it might help if you
circle it
as you'll need to remember this number
for the rest of the video
now i want you to pick a second number
and i want one condition i want that
number to be in a different row and a
different column from the first number
you've picked
so if you pick the number 10 as your
first number
the next number you pick should not be
in the same row
and it should not be in the same column
so you can pick from any of the
remaining numbers that are not in the
same row and the same column as the
first number you picked
i also want you to remember this number
so remember the first number you picked
and the second number you picked
you're going to repeat this process pick
a third number that's in a different row
and a different column
from the first two numbers you picked so
you don't want this number to be in the
same row or the same column as either of
the first two numbers you've picked
so now you've picked three different
numbers and i want you to remember them
because you're gonna have to do one more
thing i want you to pick a fourth number
that's also in a different row and a
different column from the previous three
numbers you've picked
so if you followed along correctly
you've now picked four numbers
and you played according the rules where
they were in different rows in different
columns so your numbers might end up
looking something like this
so you've got your four numbers and i
want you to add up these four numbers so
there's no way i could have known what
first number you picked what the second
number was or third or the fourth but
now here comes a prediction
add up those four numbers you have
and here's what my prediction is
my prediction is the sum of your numbers
is 34.
am i correct
if you want to know how this trick works
you can follow a link in the video
description where i describe the
mathematical proof
in a blog post
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalkar
and if you like the video please check
out my books
there is a detailed description of each
book in the video description